j'ai déjà été appelés temps je rachète
des journées je faisais des temps
supplémentaire par moments puis un matin
où juste arrivé au travail dans mon auto
et j'étais en larmes je pleurais c'était
il ya deux ans le jour où annick kirouac
a décidé de réduire sa semaine de
travail à quatre jours
elle est infirmière clinicienne à
l'urgence de la cité de la santé depuis
18 ans l'urgence un des milieux où on
est le plus à risque d'erreur quand ça
va vite on peut tourner cohérent il ya
des tas qui peut nous manquer chaque
semaine dangereux pour nous perdre le
droit de pratiquer qu'en fait des
erreurs dans les trois dernières années
ça s'est vraiment dégradée là une grande
pression qui mise sur les gestionnaires
pour les l'état de l'état de séjour à
l'urgence qui d'après sur mad et ça
jusqu'à nous et elle n'est pas la seule
à avoir réduit la cadence au 6 de laval
qui regroupe tous les établissements de
santé
il y a plus d'infirmières à temps
partiel cas temps plein c'est souvent
par choix pour compléter des études ou
pour éviter le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire la charge de travail est
déjà élevé les infirmières sont obligés
de faire du temps supplémentaire
puis le jeudi sont vraiment obligé c'est
pas moi ce soir saint julien puis je
vais rester puis je vais faire un 16
heures puis non c'est toi ce soir sur
est au total il y à 150 postes
d'infirmières à l'urgence de la cité de
la santé dont une quarantaine qui sont à
combler rapidement mais il suscite peu
d'intérêt ne dépose qui ont trouvé un
truc qui ont des candidats mais on en a
plusieurs qui sont encore l'ol 000 la
direction de l'hôpital a voulu rendre
certains de ces postes plus attrayant un
poste de rotation se sait peu
intéressant non plus parce que pour
savoir pour travailler de jour de soir
ou de nuit on affiche
beaucoup c'est certain on trouve preneur
habituellement la partie patronale a
rencontré le syndicat pour trouver des
solutions au manque récurrent de
personnel on aime quand même les soins
d'urgence le sait la surchage qu'on aime
pas pour ne pas abandonner une
profession qu'elle aime année kirouac
doigté consacré moins d'heures ce
faisant elle donne moins de temps à un
hôpital qui a pourtant grand besoin de
ses services
ici anne louise despatie radio-canada
laval